so 2022 strategy yeah so um we've
uh i've been trying to
explain and introduce the idea of nfts
yes to katie um i would say that she
does not know much about it so i think
if you can provide that insight for that
i think that'd be super helpful because
you're aware of what's happening with it
like it's that it's kind of happening
yeah i've heard a lot about it just
don't know
the the biggest reason that it's hard to
understand is it's built on the
blockchain not the internet
and so like that in itself is what just
like everyone struggled with the
internet long before you were born um
and everyone was like what the [ __ ] like
what did you mean the internet like what
do you mean buying stuff like all the
stuff that we went through
um
most people don't understand the concept
of owning something digitally
like you couldn't do that on the
internet
and now you can and it can be proved and
you can't right click it and save it in
all the jokes that people make and it
will happen and so but what's
interesting about it is every nft is
actually
has the ability to also be a contract by
nature it's a contract i own this this
is mine but
you can do more things on it so for
example influencers i think are going to
really
create collectibles and pieces of art
that also underneath in the contract
have access whether virtually or in
person
so all of a sudden the cliche meet and
greet
that used to have a price point or
autograph or things of that nature
can now be sold as an nft to even be the
pass instead of a qr code or a bracelet
or an email confirmation
but what's different is
okay cool so now you make you do an
appearance and the tickets are in nft
where it gets crazy is okay so that
happens and sure somebody gonna pay you
20 for a confirmation email with a qr
code or be on the list or they buy a 20
nft and then they connect and they prove
that it's them and they come in
it's what happens after the fact after
the fact
that ticket
is a digital trading card so if somebody
then sells that for 50 bucks
or a thousand dollars or a dollar or a
million dollars
you as the issuer of the nft are getting
a royalty okay so what nfts does is puts
everybody basically into the music
business where they get royalties except
the economics for the human are so much
greater than they were when somebody
would sign a record deal you're getting
all of it or the majority of it instead
of a small sliver of it so
the think of the nft less as a piece of
art or a collectible because you may not
want your space on a collectible like i
you could want it you might not want it
both are fine
it's more of what is it trigger
it can represent something else
and that's the biggest economics to an
influencer i mean the the
you in seven years like exploding in a
year
nft infrastructure is going to make
spotlight and brand deals look amateur
hour
financially as a business
other than
you know being a model and a comedian
early instagram was a better advantage
than being a
a publisher
being a writer on blogging was better
than a tv personality type was better on
youtube on twitter quick wit or short
communicator was better
you know vine was like super micro
comedian like every time there's a
platform there's almost like a different
skill set required
with nfts the influencer
has to be incredibly focused on bringing
value forever to the community around
that nft which is a huge challenge
because most influencers are
transactional
um and there's a lot more business
strategy to launching a successful nft
project but the economics are
dramatically more interesting than
anything else that an influencer can do
so thinking about like what is it
like and then reverse engineering the
human being yeah you may love i love the
idea of getting on zoom with a hundred
of my fans and doing q a for an hour
but i don't think that makes me nice or
special when another personality doesn't
because they may be more introverted or
their creative process is different or
that might be too draining or too
chaotic
there is no wrong or right there's just
what are you and then reverse
engineering in project form
right like
it might be scary for you to do physical
meet and greets right as a younger woman
like like that i won't think about
that's okay that's just the reality of
but you may love cooking and you want to
go into that realm and
you decide your nft project's around
that and that gives everybody access to
the virtual cooking with you so it's an
avenue for expansion
outside of what you represent today for
nft forum as well
so that's another thing to think about
okay yeah i think that's definitely my
main goal is what's next and going
above and beyond what i'm doing now and
if nfts are going to be the next big
thing then
like we always want to be first like we
were with youtube we were with instagram
reels we were with snapchat so what's
next and i think being
one of
few versus one of many is like what i
focus on i think that's right and i
think that
not being crippled you know being first
is all relative to right like how you
two defined being first on those
platforms like we were in the beta on
that yeah and saw who was there so like
you know like
i think someone can consider themselves
first if they jump on youtube shorts
today it's just still early
right you know so
you know i think um
i think you know i had a million
followers on musically before it was
tick tock yeah so like what is first i
think is a great mentality
but remember that the two of you are the
subjective judge and jury on whether you
were first or not yeah nfts are you
first i mean there's a drillion
projects out there
but 99 of the world doesn't know yet
yeah so you can be first
i think forget about first a little bit
even though it's so much of the identity
like
that to me is
a good strategy
more than i think the two of you should
think of it as an identity
because what's going to really matter is
best
for community right
it's great to always be plus i it's my
career yeah but
but i wasn't first on instagram because
it was too much about photography for
the first two years and then i got busy
with vaynermedia
but when i decided to get serious about
instagram seven years in six years in
whatever the math is
i did it better and so i was able to
still be majorly successful
i think um
don't underestimate that aspect of it as
your identity gets formed on it
and then really really think about best
for community like what's in it for them
right connecting with yeah like
literally every single thing you do like
forget about even like that kind of like
the cliche like forget about like that
sentence like truly the mentality of
like why is this good for them
and they could be the lightest weight
mundane thing because they think i'm
pretty smart this is access to the
sidelines it can be anything
but if you always think about that
you've got real chance for longevity
we are finding very unique on
youtube in particular with shorts
is that um it is converting
um definitively to subscribers of course
uh which which uh when we first
started to activate on shorts um not to
say that i'm 100 surprised with it but
it was great to see that it wasn't just
views but that those that were watching
were going out of their way to click the
subscribe button which i think uh you
always hope for that but sometimes you
don't see that sometimes you see the
views but you don't see
those that's because youtube is built on
decades now at this point of subscriber
dna
even more so
for tick tick-tock
the concept of following an account
is much more foreign because your ford
you is doing it for you
it's like act literally doing it for you
so as you know you and your
contemporaries are just not as fast even
if they think something's awesome to be
like oh i'm going to follow this person
even less than
instagram or twitter
because the 4u is doing the work
whereas in youtube culture the
psychology of that same kid is i like
this
this room this game this world is so
built on subscribe you've got 2000
you've got 16 years
of almost every crater on the platform
yelling subscribe in video form in their
long form which has created the
subconscious behavior would you see why
you're seeing such a high conversion
rate to subscribe on youtube shorts yeah
and also the discovery is there too
which
um you know katie first started to
create her short form content this is
february march
um there was not a lot of shortfall
content on there that's right so you're
able to
uh to some degree be early it's always
the same that is always gonna be the
same game
strategy yes right it's real estate
if something's meant to become manhattan
it was a good idea to buy a plan yeah
different for nfts though because that's
really distribution and just when i
think about nfts and like when you say
kind of being the first of it it does
get getting energies i don't think
brings necessarily more awareness like
no but no but but like sort of interrupt
but in the macro like
gronk and mahomes and aoki
like did better with their nft projects
by doing february march
first always has
some value
um
and in in social media world to your
point a lot of value because you gather
audience that tends to stay right nft
life can be very long term if you think
about doing things that are for the long
term
the problem is most influencers are
looking most humans are looking at it as
transactional i'm selling something
which is the mindset of influencer most
the reality is most influencers make
their money on brand deals and those are
transactional behaviors today i'm going
to talk about this coffee
right right whereas if you're gonna do
an nft project the great fear is people
spend
800 bucks for something and then it's
not a priority for you to see it through
and it goes down in value or it doesn't
provide them value
and that's bad
when i decided to do re-friends it was
like [ __ ] i'm doing this for the rest of
my life otherwise
people are going to lose
that's very different than just being on
the receiving end of
them losing in branded content for him
is oh i don't want to see her ad i swipe
not i'm paying 900 bucks for a token
right
makes sense
um
i don't care you want to speak to look
it's interesting that you say brand
deals only because the way that we
approach it is i'm not going to say it's
unique
but it is a little bit different
um
yeah i mean between spotlights between
spotlight and what's going on on youtube
i get that
that it evolves differently plus your
own business ecosystem i know that
you're deep with you know because like
you're deep in her business and like
there's a lot of ways to it's just the
masses think that way but even if even
you know
even if you think about it there's an ad
land
where you're getting it from snap or
youtube or if you decided to go into
product and merch kylie and selka it's
still transaction when i sold wine and
sneakers
that was it like you bought it for 20
bucks and i'm like i made you a
delicious wine like right with nft form
it's forever
it's an economy forever
they could literally buy a token for 700
bucks maybe you doodle like i do like i
don't know where you sit but like that's
gonna get bought and the subconscious
relationship with the audience is more
sports cards
this will go up and down and you're on
the hook right a player in sports is
just playing
but if you issue the nft your tops
end bryce harper right you're both
and unlike sports like you're in control
you